[Musique]
il passera l'été chez nathan sharpe tu
m'envoies loin pour l'aider c'est
tellement cliché
ce free
[Musique]
tu fumes
tu me ramènes
[Applaudissements]
le regard qu'elle m'acheter
ça lui fendu terme m j'espérais que tu
te montres pour cent le plus penser à
autre chose
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu dirais si je voulais
vente de l'herbe avec toi et celui-là
cerezyme pas si tout le monde d'acheter
ça la vie serait beaucoup plus simple
alors il faut qu'on en vend plus
le problème c'est qu'on vend au g à d
ado il faut les clients qui prennent
plus que ça c'est pas aller mais un
bogey
tu veux pas prendre un vente de l'herbe
j'ai exactement ce que tu veux vous êtes
fait des stups c'est une bonne question
les frites peuvent pas faire ça assieds
toi c'est plus de fric on n'en verra
jamais
[Musique]
vous savez le plus
la mouiller dans un sale truc rassure
moi
ah ah ah ah
ça arrive chaque été dans l'air devient
irrespirable
reeves pas sans dormir la nuit
duprat pour que ça s'affranchissent
est ce que tu sais ce qu'ils te brisera
un petit morceau
certaines choses doivent s'arrêter
d'autres continuent geste
[Musique]